good afternoon everyone my name is
Helene from China she and Joe to
university we are talking the changing
of mounting analytical chemistry in
heritage conservation there are three
parts the first one is the importance of
analytical skill in heritage
conservation and in the second apart is
a devout treatment of this chillin in
University and the last one is
application let's just first one my
story starts from last week because last
week my university just as aids 120
years anniversary this is the landscape
of celebration and also the celebration
from other famous artists and the
president of University the money is the
president of my university I could you
lay my university start from Shanghai it
established in Shanghai after 16 years
and movie to see an and the dance in CN
for another 16 years no sorry as your
safety and Lisa so did the ancients
dating a long history must be with a lot
of cultural heritage I will take the
poly comic art works as a examples that
as you can see including grotto pitch in
between the art architecture painting
the powdery such as the framers Tyra
culture and the Warriors but what's the
many problem of these priceless cultural
heritage let's say lost over surface and
the lost of color on some deterioration
or fading or crackers this is the
problem for the student before
restoration they must be clear the
meanings Polly economic structure the
pigment the original one and the
the pending medium but for the student
how to know this this is example I give
that a name of greens pigment as you see
the first layer is Korean pigment the
middle tool sure it's a only one layer
of green but they are underdone you can
see several layers such as the first one
the original way is divided but repaired
in balloon and then repaired in green
it's a it's a typical repaired mistake
without analysis so we can say we're not
without analysis may be without
restoration yeah because because of this
reason the training program including
all of this such as xrd XRF among
material related the paper the most
difficulty one is the organic material
so I were talking the PYT semis for the
identification of organic abandon medium
it's the sacred apart when we teach in a
student we shoulda to think last
question first one day is the basic
requirement for the science degree under
the second is gives students a guidance
the integration of art understands
because they will they are qualified we
will be qualified by the slightest
degree so they need a high-quality paper
as you know the high-quality paper is
there may be more difficulty than the
pure sense in the conservation field and
so we needed to give student
encouragement the last one is employment
maybe is most important problem because
the student in the conservation field
have some limitation to find it good job
than the pure sons yes let's say the
first one is this is the molding
analytical chemistry for the gesture for
the theoretical trini the separation
that they cut the tyrosine
and training how to operate it and the
training the identification of binding
medium and a lot of bending medium has
been tuned for this student as such as a
tick are you why are you and sixty
statesville are you tomorrow is most
used in east part and but in west part
is laced in the oriole well into our yo
papa orion all of this oreo is similar
we stopped a bond in composition yes but
the different composition of a bath
double bond is so different drive speed
tomorrow is the later first in case that
because they have a similar double bound
silly have a sim analytical results such
as and the ethylenic i said is the mark
mark peak if the student refunded this
peak I called the carbon night depending
material ace orel I in China its
tutorial in our country and Billy's lady
in the Orion are other Orion also
addressed as I said we should leave
student encouragement such as is the
this paper is the nano material in art
conservation in the end of last year I
found a newspaper so they've incurred in
complimented to student yes in the
conservation field you may be published
good current paper for the higher degree
also as you know to give students a
brighter future because the maybe they
are is the long distance for the
conservation field and Nobel Prize so we
need to inquire student maybe the next
the young student will have this price
yeah
the last one the application is very
easy adjusted go to example this is the
drum tower for the afternoon in
Marseille day so we analysis the blue
color we found a cabin I its tongue are
you it's repaired or if original 1h
stronger you another example is the
temple the temple is the golden surface
and as you can see the golden surface is
on the right a layer and the picture you
can see we found the golden from the
island and the carbon-carbon is by the
material arrow is a pigment and the
coating is the surface what's the
binding medium is Troy it's dry oil
after compared with the reference so we
give a polymeric structure as the arrow
material I said a pigment and then on
the arrow material surface they were
called in a year it's for the shine ish
something like a days it's a typical
technical ancient China ok let's thermal
ray I give a lot of question and the
question is about the mystical and the
fundamental chemistry in conservation
field for the student and also the
enough time for chemistry degree and the
conservation training in four years also
maybe we have probably we have no
department for conservation in size
field for the future of a brighter
future of student such as our chemistry
or chemical art department let's think
and also the conservation and student
for the bachelor it's enough it's
effective and the conservation marster
conservation Dirac a doctor it's biter
or it's necessary let's think in the
future and the discussion thank you so
much